- Hi everyone.
I'm Saad Omer.
I'm the Director of the Yale
Institute for Global Health
as many of you are likely to know.
I am delighted to welcome
you to the first hybrid event
that we have started doing
in this new academic year
that the Yale Institute for
Global Health has started doing.
We are delighted to be here
at the Yale School of Public Health
and we welcome those who
are joining us online.
I know that a bunch of you
have been joining us online
over the last few years.
In addition to the Yale
Institute for Global Health,
today's event is co-sponsored
by the Walker Fund
at the MacMillan Center at Yale.
The COVID-19 pandemic has
highlighted the critical need
to better prepare for future pandemics.
This is not going to be the last major
infectious disease-related event.
We have already seen monkeypox.
Public health emergencies
pop up with some frequency
and there are estimates
that unfortunately,
the frequency of these kinds of events
is likely to increase.
During this event, our panelists
will present and discuss
several themes and several elements
for an effective pandemic response.
We have three very prominent,
thoughtful panelists
and speakers for today's event.
Before moving to their
presentation and our discussion,
I'm gonna introduce them together,
give you a little bit of their background
and then we are gonna go to
their respective presentations
and then the Q&A session where
I'll start with questions,
and then we'll take audience questions,
both on-site and online.
So, Dr. Jennifer Nuzzo
is the Inaugural Director
of the Pandemic Center at Brown University
School of Public Health.
Before I became the
Inaugural Director of YIGH,
I used to imagine that people
just come into their centers
on day one and cut a ribbon or something,
that's how they become
inaugural directors.
I have no such illusion anymore.
But the Center has already done
a lot of significant things
and
is becoming fairly prominent
in the discourse around
public health preparedness.
She's also a Senior
Fellow for Global Health
at the Council on Foreign Relations.
She's an epidemiologist by training.
Her work focuses on
global health security,
public health preparedness and response.
And I guess, if I can
sort of share my bias,
most importantly, on
health systems resilience.
So, we are public health people,
we go for primary prevention if possible.
So, creating a resilient health
system is in that category.
Dr. Nuzzo regularly
engages with the media,
both electronic and print
media, to educate and inform
about emerging health security trends.
Dr. Wilmot James is a
former Member of Parliament
in South Africa and ranking
opposition spokesperson
on health.
Currently, he's a Senior
Researcher Scholar
at the Institute for Social and
Economic Research and Policy
at Columbia University, just
a small train ride away,
where he leads the Center
for Pandemic Research.
He conducts research on pandemic
response and biosecurity
and convenes, with some frequency,
high-level meetings on planetary threats.
He's also an Honorary
Professor of Global Health
at University of
Witwatersrand in Johannesburg.
Beth Cameron is a Professor of
Practice of Health Services,
Policy and Practice at Brown University.
Dr. Cameron is a national
expert in health security,
pandemic preparedness,
biosecurity, biodefense,
and bioterrorism.
She has worked at the highest
level of the government,
including serving as the special
assistant to the President
and Senior Director
for Global Health Security and Biodefense
for the White House
National Security Council.
She also serves as a senior advisor
to the U.S. Agency for
International Development, USAID,
but here, is not
representing any government,
or government agency.
She's here as a professor and
in her own personal capacity
as a key opinion leader in this area.
So, we are honored to have
all three of you here today.
So, we...
For today's event, each of our panelists
will do a short presentation
followed by one, or two questions,
so, after the presentation is complete.
Actually, I would suggest that
you restrict those questions
to clarifying questions, and
any substantive questions,
we will get to them after
the initial presentation.
So, if you want any clarification,
feel free to follow up,
but if you have more
substantive questions,
we'll do that in the panel.
Obviously, for those on Zoom,
will also have an
opportunity to ask questions.
With that, I would like
to welcome Dr. Nuzzo
to deliver the presentation.
(pages rustling)
(audience applauding)
- Thank you so much.
Thanks for that kind introduction
and thanks for the invitation.
It's really such a pleasure to be here,
to learn more about the work
of people I admire so greatly,
like yourself, Saad, and your colleagues,
but also to meet with students.
We had great conversations
(object thudding)
today.
If we advance to the next
slide, we're gonna spend today
talking about how to better prepare
for these sorts of events.
That's a huge topic,
but I'm just gonna take two small pieces,
which is thinking about surveillance
and the role of surveillance
and how we can improve it
as well as the workforce,
the workforce to support
surveillance, but to some extent,
the broader public health workforce.
Prior to coming to Brown,
while I was at Johns Hopkins,
I had the privilege to be part of the team
behind the Johns Hopkins'
coronavirus map, which was started
by my Hopkins colleague,
Dr. Lauren Gardner.
I'm showing a screenshot of the map
from actually Friday of last week.
So, these are somewhat up-to-date numbers,
but I'm showing this really
as a bit of an allegory
for how we should think about
improving surveillance and data.
The first thing I wanna point out,
is that this map was created
(Jennifer chuckles)
by people outside of government
because there was nothing like it
and there was very much
a need to stay up-to-date
with the case numbers,
where they were occurring,
and to analyze those case numbers
in the context of other factors.
So, that was clearly a
need that, in my mind,
there is now at least
a mechanism to address
with the creation of the WHO Pandemic Hub,
but still, I think a long
way to go, to make sure
that we have, in future
events, something like this.
This was an extraordinary
resource intensive effort,
very expensive effort.
I'm very proud of the work
that it did, but it also,
I think, represented just a small piece
of the challenge of fixing surveillance
for these sorts of global emergencies.
Part of why we need to fix
this is not just to get
the up-to-date picture,
the dashboard that tells us
what's going on now and to
help us analyze these numbers
so that we can understand how
best to target our resources,
but we also need to understand
the context by which the data
that populate these sorts
of dashboards are generated.
And that's the real
piece that I don't think
that we're spending
enough time trying to fix.
If you could advance to the next slide.
I'm just gonna show you a
screenshot from one day.
Actually, this graph doesn't appear
on the dashboard anymore, but it used to,
and it was the daily case
numbers being reported each day
across the globe.
As you can see from this
graph, there's one day
that's not (chuckles) like the others.
There was one day, and you
can imagine on that day
when we got those case
numbers, we thought,
"What's going on?
Like, "This is an error.
"Is something else happening?
"What is going on?"
It wasn't until you kind of
parse, you look at the data
and you realize it's all
coming from one country,
and then you look in the news,
and you realize what's happening,
which is that this was a day
where a single country decided
to change its case definition.
So, one country's policy
decisions can greatly change
our understanding of how
the pandemic is unfolding
and what it means for
the global community.
And the truth is, we don't have
the standardized definitions
so that all countries are
finding and reporting cases
in the same way.
So, what we have here,
is really a hodgepodge
based on what countries decide to do.
This is one of the challenges
when we talk about global surveillance,
which is how do we
actually get a meaningful,
common global picture of what's happening,
absent standards for how
we collect these data,
how hard we look for these
data, and how we report them.
If you go to the next slide.
This is further complicated.
So, the case definition one is probably
an easier problem to solve,
but (chuckles) what underpins
our abilities to find cases
is a much harder thing
that we also need to invest in.
And that's, countries
have different capacities
to go out and look for cases.
This is a graph that's not up-to-date,
but it was taken at a point in
time showing test positivity
from different countries.
As you can see, there's a huge range.
There are some countries, like
Mexico's up here on the top,
that had very high test positivity
throughout the entire
duration of the pandemic.
What that meant
is that they were not doing
a whole lot of testing.
So, the people who were
getting tested were the people
who were highly probable of
having the SARS-CoV-2 infection
that causes COVID-19.
So, that means that broad
testing in the community,
testing people who are asymptomatic,
was largely not happening.
This isn't indeed true.
When you look at different
countries' policies
and different countries' practices,
you see a wide range in terms
of what countries were doing.
One of the things we found
in looking at these data
was that many countries were largely,
throughout much of the
pandemic, only testing travelers
because travelers paid for the tests.
What that meant is the
positive test results
were largely coming from people
who were from outside the
country, probably lower risk
because they were probably
wealthy and traveling
and not necessarily then reflective
of what was happening in country
in terms of transmission.
So, if that's what we're
rolling up into our national,
or our global surveillance
picture, then we're not getting
a real sense
(Jennifer chuckles)
of what is happening within countries.
So, beware when you see analyses that say
this country did better than this country
based on the data that
these countries reported,
recognizing that the processes
by which those data are generated
are very, very different
and do not in any way conclude
(chuckles) that capacities
(siren wailing)
may not be relevant
to those analyses because
capacities are what countries use
to not only go out and diagnose cases,
but also to count deaths and
to determine cause of death.
And if we wanna get a
standardized picture,
we need to make sure, we need
to level the playing field
and make sure all countries
have the same capacities
and equal probability of
finding cases, finding deaths,
determining cause of deaths,
and being able to report them.
Next slide.
So, that's just a very
brief snip on the data side.
There's so much more I could
say about data improvements,
but I wanna save time for the discussion.
So, I'll just kind of pause there
and then turn to
(Jennifer chuckles)
the workforce because I
do think that sometimes
we spend a lot of time talking about data
as though it's an end
point, as opposed to a tool,
an information input to a
process that's supposed to end
with a public health action
taken to make people safer.
What is needed is not just
a data point, a 1 and a 0
that your computer generates,
but people to gather the data,
to analyze the data, to act upon the data,
and then to take action
depending on where the data points us.
There are many different types
of workforce that really,
I think, are essential for this work,
but I'll just focus on one
and I'll talk about the
epidemiology workforce.
What I'm showing here is a graph from
the most recent version of the
Global Health Security Index,
which we published in the end of 2021.
This shows just a snapshot of
the epidemiologic workforce.
Clearly, you can see again,
lots of heterogeneity
across the globe in terms of
how many epidemiologists per
capita exist in countries
and I think
(sirens wailing)
it really speaks to the
continued work to make sure
we develop, train, and retain
the epidemiologic workforce.
And I put some emphasis
on that retain part
because I am deeply worried
about that going forward.
I am deeply worried (chuckles).
The United State's
colored in relatively dark
compared to other countries,
meaning we tend to have more
epidemiologists per capita
as compared to other countries,
but if you've talked to anybody
who's worked in public health departments,
you have learned that
there's been a hemorrhaging
of qualified, experienced
public health workers,
in part because they're burnt
out, they feel threatened,
they feel like
there's a better career
path for them elsewhere.
This is likely not unique
to the United States.
We've seen this in many contexts
and so, I think we've really have to worry
about the sustainability
of these workforces
and making sure we not only train them,
but we also retain them.
Next slide.
I do think though,
that it's not just about
training epidemiologists.
It's not just training
community health workers,
which I frankly think is
one area of deep deficiency
for which, if we were gonna
put efforts into any one place,
in my view, would probably be that.
Saad, to your point about
health systems resilience,
I think that's one key lesson
from our work in health systems resilience
about the importance and unmet
needs in terms of shoring up
the community health workforce.
But it's not just about
the technical skills.
It's not just about putting
people in these positions.
It's also about training
them and empowering them
to make decisions and to
act upon the information
that they have at hand to
say, "We need to do something
"and here's what we need
to do based on my training,
"based on my experiences,
"based on what I'm seeing in the data."
Again, data are not the end point.
Data, they're the start
of the process. (chuckles)
They're the information we use to act.
But what we have seen is
really a lack of empowerment
of a public health
workforce to be able to act
and to be able to act swiftly
such that we respond to events that occur
with the possibility
that they could be worse
than they might seem right now.
And let me tell you, seeing the monkeypox,
I'll just call it a debacle,
play out in the United States,
on the heels of a COVID debacle,
where delays resulted in
costs to threats to life,
seeing that yet again play out
in terms of our response to monkeypox,
a virus for which we had
more tools and frankly,
a better leg-up than we did for COVID,
I think we have to take a hard
look at how we are training
and empowering public health
workers to act on situations
such that we can get ahead of them
instead of constantly looking backwards
and leading sort of based on
our retrospective understanding
of what's happening.
Next slide.
I also think, in addition
to having the data
and having the workforce,
and obviously we can look at
what's happening in
events that are happening,
but in the interim, we need to practice.
We need to practice,
not just as a workforce
with the plans that we
have, but also as societies.
I have spent a lot of time thinking
about how pandemic threats relates
to other hazards in our life.
I spent a lot of time thinking
about how it relates to
how we think about fires.
What's clear is that when
you have a recurring hazard,
you don't just need the
capacities to deal with them.
You also need to practice
what you do when it happens.
That is something where I
think we are quite deficient
and there are, I think, more
opportunities to practice.
Prior to the pandemic,
we did a study looking at
how Taiwan conducted, every single year,
mass vaccination exercises.
They did it during the flu season.
They did it so that they could
boost uptake of flu vaccines
among the most vulnerable,
but they also did it so
that they could practice
what they would do in a pandemic.
So, not only could they test their systems
and their personnel, but
that the public would know
where to go to get a vaccine,
so that in an emergency
it wouldn't feel like this weird thing
that showed up out of nowhere.
That it was the thing that you do,
just like we do regular fire drills
so that when the alarms go off for real,
we don't spend critical time
trying to convince ourselves
it's not really happening.
We just act because it feels familiar.
We rely on that muscle memory.
And I think we need to do
more of that in public health.
Next slide.
Then finally, I talked
about this sustainment issue
and the point that we can't just buy
these single-use solutions
every time we have an emergency.
We can't just take a whole lot of money,
try to hire a whole
lot of contract workers
and then as soon as the
case numbers come down
and the funding lapses, we let them all go
and then we find ourselves scrambling
when the next event happens.
We have to sustain it.
This is, I have data here
from the United States,
but I think this is playing out
in many, many places across the globe
where we have that initial
emergency response,
and then we get tired and we
move on to other priorities.
So, this is just what public
health preparedness looked like
in the early 2001, 2002, 20003.
So, 2001, some of you may
be too young to remember,
but the nation experienced a real shock
in terms of the events of September 11th
and a real commitment
to never again make sure
that we are unprepared for
public health emergencies.
So, there was a real increase
in the amount of funding
and that was sustained for quite a while
and the peak was around
2005 where, I would say,
that was probably the time
when our preparedness
programs were the strongest.
But then, if you go to the next slide,
you'll see over time,
that commitment lapsed.
These data cut off before, I think,
the worst of what we saw
happen in public health,
which was the economic downturn of 2008
where we know that there
was a hemorrhaging of staff
from health departments
as state budgets basically contracted.
We saw this play out
in other places around the world as well.
2008 Represented a real departure point
in terms of our preparedness programs
and it was also accelerated by the fact
that national funding for
these programs dried up
at the same time that the
economic crisis really strained
local budgets.
Next slide.
This has consequences.
This has real consequences.
(Jennifer chuckles)
This boom-and-bust cycle
has real consequences.
One of them was, just before the pandemic,
we interviewed health departments
around the United States,
asking them about their
response to the measles outbreak
that were happening before the pandemic.
One of the questions we asked them about,
was contact tracing, the extent
to which they were employing
contact tracing in responding
to these measles outbreaks.
If you don't know anything about measles,
it is the clearest case for the need
to use contact tracing.
(Jennifer chuckles)
Measles is a highly transmissible virus
and wanting to put a
large circle around it
is really quite important.
But what we found, is that
most health departments
were not using contact tracing.
They didn't have the workforce
to do contact tracing.
So, when they had measles outbreaks,
basically all they were doing
was kind of putting up a notice saying,
"If you were in these
places during these times,
"you may have been exposed to measles.
"Call your healthcare provider."
Great, if you tell the
healthcare provider what to say.
Great, if you actually have a
healthcare provider to go to.
And we certainly know that
both of those situations
(Jennifer chuckles)
are not necessarily true.
We saw a degradation in capacity
just before the pandemic
and the consequences of that
were very clear in the pandemic
when we needed an emergency supplemental
to suddenly hire all of
these contract workers
to do the work of contact tracing,
which if you know anything
about contact tracing,
is more like an art than
a science and really hard
to just drop in place and have
it be effective overnight.
Next slide.
This is really my last content
slide, which is to say,
despite what you may have heard last night
about the pandemic being over,
I don't think that it is,
(chuckles) but even if you think
that the emergency of COVID is over,
even if you think that 500+ deaths a day
is no longer an emergency,
I don't, but if you do,
you should not take
from the ending of COVID
that this is a once in a century crisis,
and we have 99 more years of safety.
The fact is and, Saad, you alluded to this
in your opening remarks,
the frequency with which we are
having these sorts of events
is increasing.
There will be more.
So, these investments in
surveillance and workforce,
and many, many, many other
components of preparedness
have to be viewed as fixed costs,
maintaining an infrastructure
that appropriately addresses
the hazards of our times,
which is infectious disease emergencies.
So, with that, thank you.
(audience applauding)
- [Saad] Take a couple
of clarifying questions.
- Any clarifying questions? (chuckles)
Okay.
Yeah.
- [Audience Member] Thank you
so much for the presentation.
I worked on one of the first
federal vaccination sites
in Oakland, one of those mass
(object scraping)
vaccine sites,
and we really were building
stuff from scratch.
I'm really wondering,
are there other reasons
as to why public health departments
are notoriously underfunded
for pandemic operations?
Are they allocating
budgets to other things?
Are there other reasons for that?
- So, quick response.
What we found... We did another
study actually looking at
mass vaccination capabilities
at health departments
and one of the things we found is that
health departments tended
to work on building plans
to hand out pills because
they were working around
an anthrax response scenario
rather than a vaccination
strategy scenario,
which is a very, very different one.
In part because of not enough resources
to do those sorts of plans,
but also they had to do
mass vaccination efforts
in some part during the 2009 pandemic.
And we very frequently heard
from health departments,
"Yeah, we used to have plans for 2009,
"but the person who worked on those plans
"is no longer here."
- [Audience Member] Okay.
- So.
(Saad speaking softly)
- Yeah.
- [Audience Member] Why is
infectious disease frequency
increasing, outbreaks?
- Yeah, (sighs) it's sort of
the conditions of our times
in the globe.
We are much more connected
than we ever were,
so we do a lot more travel than we did.
So, that just gives the
ability for people to mix
in ways they didn't mix and
to bring things with them.
Also, we are encroaching into
areas that put us in contact
with pathogens that we may
not have had contact with.
Environmental drivers of
pathogen emergence and spillover
is increasing and then we, as a society,
are more vulnerable to these things.
We have higher levels of chronic illness,
vaccine coverage has lapsed,
and so that just makes us
(device pinging)
more vulnerable
to infectious diseases in general.
That's why you're hearing
about measles and polio
and (chuckles) things that
we didn't have to talk about
20 years ago quite as much again.
- Thank you.
Our next speaker is Dr. Wilmot James.
There are a lot of endearing
qualities about him
and one being, that I just noticed,
that he has a stopwatch in his phone.
I think that's certainly the academic side
of his personality,
not the politician side of his personality
because politicians don't
know when to stop speaking.
(audience chuckling)
It's only the professors
who are timed by other
classes lining up outside.
So, thanks.
- Thank you.
Thank you very much indeed, to Dr. Saad
and for the invitation
from Yale University
to speak here today.
To tell you the truth,
when I was in the South African
Parliament, you're given
(phone ringing)
five minutes to speak.
Normally, that means that
they will shut it down
after five minutes.
It's something called the guillotine,
(audience chuckling)
which means
you work on 100 words per
minute and you practice it.
(audience chuckling)
So,
with that being said,
(claps hands)
let me speak about
the subject of vaccines.
So, I can get the next
slide, my disclaimer slide.
No conflicts of interest and just thanks
to all of those individuals
for being of assistance.
The next slide, please.
So, colleagues, there's a
growing consensus in the world
that we need to do three things.
We need to focus on three areas of work.
The first has to do with
training and educating
a new generation of
individuals in public health
and clinical medicine with
high levels of expertise
in a distributed way,
globally and to network.
The second is to upscale surveillance.
And we speak a lot about
(device chirping)
real-time surveillance.
We actually don't have
global systems of real-time surveillance.
This is a 10-year long project.
Not easy to do.
The third is to have
a decentralized system
of vaccine manufacturing in the world.
So, I'm gonna focus on that.
As you can see on the screen,
there is now a commitment
to developing vaccines within 100 days,
which is breathtaking.
The innovation during
COVID-19 was breathtaking
in terms of the speed
of vaccine production
and using new technology platforms.
After our experience now, we
need to capture lessons learned
from this period of vaccine development.
We need to deliver
options for the expansion
of manufacturing capacity
in low and middle-income countries
and we need to establish a
delivery and accountability plan.
Those are the three elements.
And I'd like just to share
with you some thoughts
about what's happening in Africa.
Next slide, please.
The framework is being
set largely through CEPI
and its plan to work
towards shortening the time
that it takes to produce
vaccines to 100 days.
It really is quite
incredible what is happening
in the world of modern
science today during COVID-19.
This is an effort to even improve it
and they think it's possible
with the right strategic focus,
timing, funding and so on.
Next slide, please.
Let me just say that,
and you would know this,
so I would just repeat
this, vaccines are among
the greatest achievements
of modern health science.
It's one of the most effective
public health interventions
available.
To note, for those of you who follow this,
vaccination, immunization
rates are falling
in many countries.
1 In 5 children in Africa
still do not receive
all of the necessary and basic vaccines
and as of 2015, Africa accounted for 33%
of the world cases of
vaccine preventable diseases
in children under 5.
You can see the chart on the
right hand side indicating
what that 33% amounts to cumulatively.
Next slide, please.
Just to note that governments
in Sub-Saharan Africa
spend, on average, $73
per capita on healthcare.
That is less than 2% of
the per capita spending
by high-income governments
and well below their national needs.
The figure on the right hand side
provided by the World Bank.
I'm sorry, it's not the best
slide, but the bottom one,
you can see what the contrast
is between the investment made
by government in Sub-Saharan Africa
compared to high-income countries.
That's per capita.
That is not a crude figure.
So, you can see where
the slack lies presently.
Next slide, please.
It is estimated that every $1 spent
on childhood immunizations in Africa
returns $44 in economic benefits,
just looking at the
economic benefit side of it.
And the four major vaccine
preventable diseases
collectively cost the African
region $13 billion each year.
So, there is the case.
It saves lives, it extends lives,
it saves money in terms of
the impact in the longer term.
It is a completely worthwhile
intervention and investment
from a moral point of view,
from a lifesaving point of view
and from an economic point of view.
At the same time, Africa
produces less than 1%
of its vaccine needs.
So, there's the case to be made.
It's a case to be
presented to politicians.
Next slide, please.
Just demographically,
2030, Africa will have
a working population
of 1 billion people.
And secondly, really
important point to emphasize
in my estimation, you've
got six months in fact.
It's a small window of opportunity
to introduce
whole-of-government-initiatives
to support the establishment
of an integrated comparative
and cohesive vaccine manufacturing market
for the African continent.
COVID-19 was tragic,
but COVID-19 illustrated
the value of investing in preparedness,
including in manufacturing of vaccines.
The picture on the right
hand side just tells you
what the benefits are in fact.
Next slide, please.
This particular illustration
tells you what's going on
in Africa presently, in terms
of vaccine-related activity.
The data on the slide is three weeks old
and we update it regularly.
But this is a fairly current picture
and there's one update I'd
like to share with you.
To note that the WHO has introduced
a mRNA vaccine transfer technology hub.
It's based in South Africa,
in the City of Cape Town
and where I am from, and
has identified seven spokes
as sites for vaccine manufacturing.
That is hugely ambitious.
We believe that South
Africa and Senegal presently
have the greatest potential
and are focusing on that.
The countries involved as
targeted entities presently
are Kenya, Rwanda, Senegal,
South Africa, and Ghana
as the sites.
The second category,
are all the other industrial partnerships.
Let me just say that presently,
there is no end-to-end
vaccine manufacturing
for human applications in
Africa at all presently.
What we have is fill-and-finish.
There is a history of end-to-end
vaccine manufacturing,
starting off with RND and
ending up with a product
for animals, but even the
underinvestment in that
has led to a degradation of that system,
largely in South Africa, in
a place called Onderstepoort,
which is outside of Pretoria.
When it comes to plants,
that's another story for another occasion.
So, what has emerged, are
other industrial partnerships
using non-mRNA platforms.
You can see what the
list looks like there,
Algeria, Morocco, South
Africa, Egypt, Nigeria,
Botswana, Uganda
and what the list is of
developments underway.
An update, is that Aspen PharmaCare,
which is the biggest
pharmaceutical company
on the African continent,
which had a license
to fill-and-finish J&J, has signed a deal
with the Serum Institute of India
to produce four lines of vaccines.
We don't know what those lines are.
We will discover.
So, what you see is a
pharmaceutical company partnering up
with the Serum Institute of India,
which of course sees Africa as its market
and will cultivate that,
or by way is saying,
that here the private sector is leading,
It's not government that's
leading on the initiatives.
I just wanted to point
out, you see down the line,
Botswana, somebody called
Patrick Soon-Shiong.
Patrick Soon-Shiong is a
South African physician.
Has been in Los Angeles.
Made an enormous amount
of money on an IP issue
when it came to cancer
and is now one of the
wealthiest people in the U.S.
He owns the LA Times, and
he has decided to invest
in vaccine manufacturing,
both in Botswana,
as well as South Africa.
The Botswana operation is
running together with Peter Hotez
and the Baylor College of Medicine
and uses traditional means
of producing vaccines.
The next slide, please.
This is the amount of money
that's flowing into Africa presently.
It's 1.5 billion euros with
300 million euros to be raised.
It's a lot of money, but on
the grander scheme of things,
is not that much.
To note that the money is philanthropic,
the money is bilateral, and
the money is also multilateral
and that Africa itself is
contributing very little to that.
To make this sustainable, will
require greater commitment
on the part of African
governments to, in fact, invest
in vaccine manufacturing.
The major challenges,
people are sort of mesmerized by mRNA.
There's no way we can use mRNA
platforms to produce vaccines
in Africa as a whole.
It has to be a combination,
a smart combination.
It focuses on Afri-specific diseases,
both emerging ones and existing ones.
To be sustainable, you need to do both.
You need to produce for an African market
for routine immunization, as
well as pandemic scale-up,
scale-down dynamic response.
Getting it done as a business
requires a whole range of interventions
that would make the durancy
of it possible and so on.
So, all what we're saying,
this is not straightforward.
Next slide, please.
So, to meet the public health challenge,
countries have organized
on a national, regional and
continental level in Africa.
They emerged
the Partnership for African
Vaccine Manufacturing,
which is an initiative of the AU
and at the multilateral and global level,
WHO vaccine technology transfer hubs
involve the WHO and its partners.
The next slide, please,
We set up something called
VacTask in response to a request
by the South African
Government for a team of us
to help them get in the business
of manufacturing vaccines.
So, we set up VacTask, it's called.
It's an independent advisory
body to governments.
It's working as a front runner
for the Partnership for
African Vaccine Manufacturing.
It's supporting an effort to harmonize
the regulatory environment.
This is both product
regulation and price regulation
and financial regulation,
but in this case,
product regulation by way
the African Medicines Agency.
There're 54 countries in Africa.
If you wanna make vaccines
and need approval of all 55,
it's a nightmare, right?
So, there's an effort
to have an AMA do that.
This is not gonna be straightforward,
but we need that facility.
The purpose of VacTask, just
finally, is to accelerate
and expand Africa's R&D
manufacturing drives,
checking on my time,
and therapies.
Next slide, please.
This is who we are.
It's chaired by Jeremy
Farrar at Wellcome Trust.
I co-chair it.
You can see it's a very
distinguished list of individuals
being part of VacTask.
Next slide, please.
What we've done to date is,
we conducted a first fact-finding
mission to South Africa.
We're currently finalizing a report,
a set of policy recommendations
to be presented to the
South African Government.
We've also hosted virtual meetings
on the latest developments
in pandemic response.
The next slide, please,
We are concerned and make
recommendations about four things.
First to get procurement right.
There needs to be harmony
in procurement internally.
You can't have the
Health Department procure
on the basis of price
and you don't talk to Trade and Industry.
So, there needs to be
internal coordination
and then there has to be
continental coordination.
Secondly, the need for
human capital investment
in manufacturing skills.
That is not the science part,
which is in reasonable
shape in South Africa,
but in good manufacturing practice.
Those skills are absent.
You deal with them by importing
those skills immediately,
but you need to train a
pipeline of people in that area.
Third point I already
made about the regulation.
The regulatory environment
needs to be upgraded
on a major scale,
and there has to be also R&D
infrastructure investment
and in adjacent industries
along the value chain
as we move through.
The slide on the right hand side,
is just to illustrate and
also to amplify the fact
that the biggest
investment that we can make
is in human skill.
That's the biggest one.
And that takes a while,
but that's something that's
an important challenge.
The next slide, please.
We can do all of that,
but if people, (chuckles),
if people don't trust vaccines,
and if they don't believe
that is a good thing to have,
it's a kind of pointless exercise.
Right now, Africa's sitting
with a surplus of vaccines.
They don't know what to do with it.
So, what's important is to have
a model for vaccine take-up
and just very quickly.
This is the environment
in which you're operating.
You can see that when it
comes to trust in science,
Sub-Saharan Africa,
(object thudding)
is the lowest
and is declining.
The next slide, please.
When you look at trust in scientists,
you can see the same thing.
So, also very low and declining.
The next slide, please.
Believe that sources base
coronavirus-related decisions
on scientific advice by region.
You can see the level of
distrust in the world.
Also, Sub-Saharan Africa is quite low,
but the lowest is Russia and
the Caucuses in Central Asia.
Next slide, please.
These are the categories of people
that are the most trusted in the world,
starting off with doctors and nurses
and ending at the bottom,
religious leaders.
The next slide, please.
Okay, so that's the context
in which we are operating.
So, we started a project where
we wanted to interview people
who, at the late stage,
come for vaccinations
to understand what the barriers were.
This is unique in a sense, this study,
because these are late
stage wait-and-see people
who come for vaccination
and once you interview them.
We are running the project
in South Africa and Zimbabwe.
The next slide.
This is a publication we made.
The next slide, please.
This is to the next slide,
we just wanted to assess
what the attitudes are
to vaccine mandates.
The next slide, please.
The key thing there is
that there was a high
percentage of individuals
who supported the use
of vaccines in Zimbabwe.
You had the normal pattern
where high-income people
had the least support
and low-income people the most support.
The reason has very little to
do with education, or income,
but to how many women in
particular fall into the category
of those who had the most
support to our vaccine mandates.
The important thing was,
is a discovery we found,
if you can show the next
slide, please, is that
the individuals who were key to the answer
around vaccine acceptance,
were mothers of children,
even in deep rural Zimbabwe.
It's said they had the most
questions about vaccine safety.
"Who tested it?
"Where was it approved?" and so on.
And clearly you can
understand it's kinda obvious
that that would be the case.
So, just to say around
drivers of vaccination,
the trusted sources of information
were Ministry of Health.
Your main information methods for them
were traditional media.
And the most important
influences had to do
with who it was that
loved them, basically.
Those were the ones who
made the real difference
in terms of accepting vaccines.
Next slide.
I've 10 seconds left, I think.
These were the main
barriers to vaccination.
As you can see that more
women had major concerns
about the side effects than men.
The relationship between
involved in education
and also internet use.
You can see what the story is there.
But let me just conclude by
saying, with the next slide,
that in the case of South Africa,
what we found is an
age grading in terms of
what the impact was of both media
and what the impact was of
the different influences.
And you can see that between 18 and 34,
what the differences were.
All by way of saying
that, the final slide,
that what the world needs
to do is develop model
for successful vaccine
uptake, modulated by region,
by country and by culture to introduce
as part of pandemic
preparedness for the next time
because we actually did
not know what we were doing
in terms of driving our vaccination rates.
And so, that's my concluding note,
is that none of this matters,
unless there are evidence-based
models for vaccine take-up
built into the planning
DNA for the next pandemic.
And with that, thank you very much.
(audience applauding)
- Thank you for an insightful talk.
If there are any, again,
clarifying questions.
Yeah, Stan.
- [Stan] The
circumstances of very large
vaccine companies are such
that Merck, for example,
can take a chance,
make COVID vaccines, they don't work.
They've lost tens of millions
of dollars, and they move on.
In the face of the
incipient manufacturers
in Africa of which,
I think you had seven sites,
presumably they don't have
the kind of deep pockets
of a Merck and presumably
they're quite vulnerable
to a particular vaccine
they produce and manufacture
and not having a market
and the whole enterprise could go under.
So, what is the intent
of the global community
to ensure a reasonable
number of purchased vaccines
so that that never happens?
- So, if I may.
Stan, it's a wonderful question.
It doesn't quite fit into
the clarifying category.
Is it okay if it's the first
question I ask him after
in the panel?
Would you be comfortable
with that? Okay. Thank you.
Appreciate that.
- Okay.
- Okay. Thank you.
- All right. Thanks.
- I just wanna,
trying to keep everyone on time, thanks.
So, the next speaker is Dr. Beth Cameron.
And yeah, your presentation.
- Thanks.
Hi everybody, I think we go.
Awesome.
Well, I'm going to be
speaking a little bit
about the architecture that we need.
And we've heard from both Wilmot and Jen
about some of the tools that
we need at the national level,
at the regional level,
and the global level.
I'm gonna talk with, I'm
gonna try, to get us up
to the level of talking about
the whole architecture we need
for global health security
and pandemic preparedness.
I'm gonna give you my
bottom line up-front,
on the first slide, which
is we need to be faster,
we need to have systems and we
need to practice every time.
Jen alluded to this,
when she talked about the firehouse model.
Nobody, when we think about a hurricane
and hurricane preparedness,
nobody looks at a community
that is narrowly escaping
a category for a hurricane
and asks, "Why did we
have so many sandbags? or,
"Why did we evacuate?"
In fact, everyone's grateful
that nothing happens.
We need to get in the
mentality of overacting
and that means we have to
have the systems ready to go,
and we have to know exactly
what we're doing every time.
Next slide, please.
I just wanted to start
with the consequences.
These are the consequences.
And I think it's pretty
obvious to all of us
who've been experiencing the
pandemic, but this slide,
three years ago when Jen,
Wilmot and I were talking about
our last project together
before the pandemic started,
this was a pretty unimaginable slide.
Next slide.
These are really the consequences.
People lost their lives.
The economy lost trillions.
Proliferation of
disinformation and mistrust.
Government struggled.
Next slide.
Public health and other
governmental officials
and communities hesitated,
but there were also a lot of
incentives against acting fast.
There were disincentives for acting fast.
What I mean by that, is
that the national level,
when you don't have a system
that everybody recognizes
as the way that you're
gonna spring into action
to respond to a public health emergency
that are a international concern,
you're making a decision on your own,
for your own community,
for your own government,
even for your own region.
And there are big consequences
to getting it wrong
if you don't have trust
that the way that you're
going to respond and act
is a certain way every time.
Next slide.
I'm gonna really start by just defining
what I mean by global health security
because it's a term we use a lot.
We also use pandemic preparedness.
We use health system strengthening.
Global health security, in my mind,
is being prepared to
prevent, detect and respond
to public health emergencies
that have high consequences,
including public health emergencies
of international concern,
whether they're naturally
occurring, accidentally caused,
or deliberately caused.
So, in all of those cases,
that's health security.
It's a piece of the health system,
but it's not the only piece.
Next slide.
I think it's important to
actually look at the nesting.
It's hard to tell with a red here,
but these are interlocking circles.
I see health security and
that broader health system
as not in conflict with one another.
But sometimes those terms
are defined that way,
so I wanted to just state my
view on this topic up front,
that preparing for pandemics is a piece
of being prepared for an outbreak
that might happen on a
national, or a regional basis,
is a piece of our broader health system.
So doctors, nurses, and access to care,
which is absolutely vital
for pandemic preparedness,
and it's all a piece of our
broader global health system.
So, all of this, in order to
be prepared for a pandemic,
we need to have systems that
work at all of these levels.
Next slide.
This is a slide that
I drew from a document
that Jen also referenced,
which is the Global Health Security Index,
a project that all three of us have worked
on over the last couple of years.
This is a map that just shows
preparedness by country.
This was put together
by the Economist Impact,
by the Nuclear Threat Initiative,
by the Johns Hopkins
Center for Health Security
and now the Brown University
is part of it too.
It looked at over 100 questions,
all WHO member states,
and it asked what capacities
are there in place
to be prepared, to prevent,
to detect and respond?
But it also looked at other capacities.
So, it looked at things
that were particular
to the ability of a country to
be prepared for an outbreak,
or a public health emergency,
like your laboratory system,
your public health workforce,
your ability to vaccinate your people.
It also looked at things like
numbers of doctors and nurses.
It looked at trust in government.
It looked at trust in
science in the last version,
and it looked at a country's ability
to deal with crises in general.
Next slide.
The bottom line is the
average score taken together
across all those countries,
was 38.9 out of 100.
That's just what countries could do.
That doesn't necessarily mean
that they even used those capacities.
This tool was not
intended to be predictive
of how countries could do.
Simply was meant to look at
what countries would be able
to do if they actually mustered
the capacities that they had.
Next slide.
I wanna talk about architecture
and what existed before COVID-19
in order to fill those preparedness gaps
and be prepared to respond in the face
of an emerging infectious
disease threat like COVID-19.
Drawing back to SARS, to
the SARS epidemic in 2003,
the international health regulations,
which is essentially the agreement
that World Health Organization
member states have
with one another saying that
they all plan to be prepared
for a public health emergency
of international concern,
were updated.
They were updated because
the world recognized,
back in 2003 when SARS hit,
that countries were not prepared
to deal with a public health emergency.
The world gave a deadline of 2012
in order for all countries to be prepared.
In that intervening time, what happened
because the IHRs were good, but imperfect
in that they didn't define
exactly what countries needed
to do in order to be prepared.
And when countries hit the 2012 mark,
they either didn't know,
or they didn't know about each
other's level of preparedness
because there was no
publication, no record,
of how prepared countries actually were.
There was no red, yellow, green
sort of stoplight mechanism.
So, following 2005 and then
into 2012, when we recognized
that most countries weren't
actually going to hit
the deadline that was put into place,
the Ebola epidemic hit in 2014.
There was a lot of work
already going on post-2012,
this deadline that everyone missed.
And countries decided they
were going to put in place
a scoring scheme to actually tell
whether or not countries
were prepared themselves
and to be able to send people
to each other's borders
to actually look at
how prepared they were.
The WHO Joint External Evaluation
Tool was put into place
to do that.
You can actually go online and look at
how prepared countries
are at the WHO website.
We used a lot of these
questions and added to those
as the basis for the Global
Health Security Index,
which you can also go online
and look at preparedness
for every country.
Around the same time, many
governments, over 60 governments,
launched something called the
Global Health Security Agenda,
which is a coalition of
countries that decided,
"We should meet regularly to talk about
"how prepared countries
are for pandemics."
During this period of time,
this rough period of time
during which H1N1 influenza
happened, Ebola happened,
SARS happened, Zika happened.
Countries were worried
about influenza cases, H7N9
and H5N1, which were high consequence,
but weren't spreading as
an epidemic, or a pandemic.
A lot happened.
Budgets actually did
increase for health security
in some spaces,
but not across our whole public
health preparedness space.
Looking at Jen's slide,
totally agree with her.
Nonetheless, when you look
at that massive level of gap,
38.9 out of 100, when you
look at the huge swath of work
to be done on things like,
how do we make vaccines,
how do we deliver them,
how do we distribute them,
how do we deal with vaccine update,
funding and political will
was wholly insufficient
to be prepared.
And we didn't have sort
of recognized systems
for how we would spring
into action, or triggers
for those systems to work
when an emerging infectious
disease threat like COVID-19,
came to call.
Next slide.
So, what resulted is that
a lot had to be created
from scratch, on the fly, in 2020.
This is an example of a lot of great work
that happened during the pandemic,
but it wasn't in existence beforehand.
So, as one key example,
the ACT Accelerator,
the Access to COVID-19 Tools Accelerator,
was created in 2020 by governments,
by non-governmental organizations,
by international organizations
like the WHO, like UNICEF,
Wellcome Trust, the Gates
Foundation, multiple governments,
the Global Fund against
HIV Aids, TB and Malaria,
Gavi, the Vaccine Alliance,
came together and said,
how are we going to get tools
like supplies, vaccines,
tests, therapeutics, personal
protective equipment, oxygen
to countries that don't
have access to these things?
So, that was created on
the fly during the pandemic
and it's a great example
of what can be done.
There's also a lot cropping
up about how it could,
or maybe could be improved,
for the next pandemic.
But this is a big open question.
How will it be maintained?
Which pieces of it will be maintained?
What is the best way to
keep this work going?
And how do we fund that work?
Regions like the African
Union, and Wilmot talked a lot
about some of the work
to manufacture vaccines,
there's also an African
Union platform called AVAT
that came online in order
to distribute vaccines
on the African continent.
So, regions working with
the global architecture,
it was bumpy.
There wasn't always agreement
on how that would work,
but these structures are in existence now
and we need to figure out as a world,
how best to maintain
and move them forward.
COVAX came into play, which
is the vaccine platform piece
of the Act Accelerator.
The G7, the world's
largest economies, the G20,
they all raised a lot of
money, billions of dollars,
in order to be able to
fill some of these gaps.
Finally, this year, the
world agreed, the WTO agreed
(device pinging)
to waive
intellectual property on
COVID-19-related vaccines.
All of this, there were
Presidential Summit
that the U.S. Government and
other spurred into action.
So, a lot of work happened,
but still we landed in a place
where millions of people died
and we didn't have the
systems that we needed.
So, this is the architecture as it exists
and what happens next,
next slide, is really a big open question.
So, I'm gonna talk for
just a couple more minutes
about where some of this might go
and what recommendations there are.
Some things that have been done,
some things that have not yet been done,
but I wanna make it
really clear to everyone
that this is an open question
that still needs to be shaped
with agreement around the world
and it's being actively
discussed this week
at the UN General Assembly.
Next slide.
So, I highly recommend
if you haven't looked
at some of the reports that
have come out, I do think
that the international
experts that were commissioned
to do a number of reports,
that I've mention,
did a great job doing them
and there's some really great
executive summaries
(audience member coughs)
that I think really put in...
A lot of converging recommendations
came out of this pandemic so far.
The G20 High-Level Independent Panel
looked primarily at financing.
Do we have enough money to
prepare for the next pandemic?
Do we have enough money
to be able to respond
to the next pandemic?
And where is it going to come from?
What's the role of
multilateral development banks
like the World Bank.
And also, do we need a new
fund for pandemic preparedness?
That is one recommendation
that was acted on,
I'm really happy to say.
Just a couple of weeks ago,
the World Bank did launch
a new fund for pandemic
preparedness with over $1.4 billion.
It's not enough.
The vision is to have at
least $10 billion a year
for this fund, but it
is a big step forward
and it is a recommendation that was shared
by a number of international experts.
And it's something that
the U.S. Government
and other partners around
the world really pushed for.
At the same time, the Independent Panel
for Pandemic Preparedness
and Response, the IPPPR,
under the leadership of
Ellen Johnson Sirleaf,
the Former President of Liberia
and Helen Clark, the Former
Prime Minister of New Zealand,
put out a report that
focused a lot on leadership
and governance for the
next pandemic threat.
They recommended a Global
Health Threats Council,
a set of world leaders
that would meet regularly
on pandemic threats, should come together
and that should have
happened in the last year.
That recommendation has
not yet been acted upon.
So, it's a piece of the architecture
that is still out there in question.
Wilmot alluded to the 100 Days Mission.
This is in effect, a recommendation
that came out of the United
Kingdom's G7 presidency
last year, to be able, on
a very systematized basis,
to look at all emerging,
potentially pandemic pathogens
and develop platforms
for vaccine candidates,
so that we can basically be
ready to do clinical trials
and then scale
and produce vaccines
(siren wailing)
for almost any emerging
potential pathogens.
This is a really great playbook,
but it is not yet funded
and there isn't yet a roadmap
for how we're actually going
to then produce those vaccines.
I think Wilmot did a
great job of laying out
some of the challenges there,
The Lancet Commission published
a large set of recommendations
just last week,
some of which converge
(siren wailing)
with these other documents
and some of which are also new.
So, there's a lot of
work that's been done.
Not all of it's been acted on.
Next slide.
There's also a question
about what we're going to do
about accidental and
deliberate biological events.
All of the technologies that we need
to be able to be prepared
for the next pandemic threat
are absolutely vital,
but also, we run the risk
of inadvertently creating the catastrophe
that we're trying to prevent
if that technology is misused,
accidentally, or on purpose.
So, there's a movement to
launch a new organization called
the International Biosecurity
and Biosafety Initiative
for Science to bring
together funders of research,
the private sector, and governments
in order to tackle this issue.
And the Nuclear Threat Initiative
is launching this effort
this fall.
That's another piece of the architecture
that has not yet been formed,
but is starting to be built.
Next slide.
When we look at the diagram on the right,
these are my go-to pieces
for the global health
security architecture,
the pandemic preparedness
architecture that we need.
When we look at financing,
we've made some strides
at preparedness financing with
the launching of the new fund
a couple of weeks ago.
There's not yet agreement
though, on things like
how do we get surge financing into place,
so that low income countries
can get in line to buy vaccines
early on in the next pandemic.
That's a big open question
that still needs to be resolved
in order to make the
manufacturing architecture,
that Wilmot outlined, actually work.
Country capacity, huge number
of gaps in country capacity,
but increasing political will and interest
and probably a window with
COVID-19 and now monkeypox,
to maintain interest at the
highest levels of government
in actually filling those gaps.
That's critical that these two things
are related to one another.
That donors, that this
new fund in that countries
look at their massive number
of gaps in many cases,
including in our own country
and prioritize which gaps to fill
and how that will actually
make them more prepared.
So, there's technical work,
but also political work
that needs to be done here.
On access to medical
countermeasures in a crisis,
a lot happened that's
really COVID-19 specific
with the ACT Accelerator being created,
with COVAX being created,
with regional organizations
like AVAT being created,
but none of that has been
agreed on, or concretized
for other emerging pandemic threats.
That's another big open question.
On political will, there
has not been agreement
to create a new structure,
like a global health threats council.
In the absence of that, here are questions
about who will ring the alarm
bell at the highest levels
in the next 2020 scenario that we face.
And then finally, accountability.
So, there has been a movement,
one that the U.S. Government
has supported, among others,
to amend the International
Health Regulations,
to make them sharper,
to make the reporting
requirements more specific.
And there's also an active
negotiation in Geneva
around the need for a pandemic
instrument, or treaty,
to bring some of this
together and sort of glue it.
Next slide.
So, I'm just gonna leave you with this.
What this is supposed to represent,
is that we have all the
ingredients that we need.
Maybe the only good thing that's
come out of this pandemic,
is we now have all the tools.
We have the ingredients, we
have the thought leadership
that we need in order to make the systems
that will make us prepared for
anything that comes our way.
But now we really need the
recipes and the practice
so that the next time we
actually are prepared,
and we can actually bake whatever
it is that you wanna bake,
that would taste
(Beth chuckles)
the best to you and we need
to be prepared to do it
every single time, using
the tools that we now have.
I'll stop there.
(audience applauds)
- Any clarifying questions
from Beth initially?
Are you stretching or raising your hand?
- Oh, sorry.
(audience member sniggers)
- Okay. That's fine.
Just checking.
All right, so we can go to the panel now.
So, we'll come as promised,
we'll come to Dr. Stan Bowman's question.
And that will be your question.
If you remember, you can--
- I do.
- Start, or we can ask
Dr. Bowman to rephrase.
- First of all, to say,
that's a great question.
So, you know, vaccines
are all about volume.
And the African market is
one market and most companies
would have to look at the bigger picture
in terms of providing it.
That's the first point.
The second is that vaccines
things are made by industry,
They're made by companies.
They're not made by
governments and therefore
there has to be collaboration
with industry on this effort.
So, governments are (indistinct) enable
Third is the point I made before.
It has to be a combination,
a smart combination,
of routine, immunization,
manufacturing and supply
together with the ability
to scale up and scale down
the pandemic.
I'm making very general
points, but that's required.
For it to be sustainable
(object clatters)
beyond the initial investments,
(zipper scratching)
African governments would have
to put somebody on the table
for this issue, and that's
gonna take some political work.
- Okay.
(faintly speaking)
- There's really not yet a roadmap
for when you look at something
like the 100 Days Mission,
which is incredibly ambitious,
the ability to make a vaccine
for any potentially pandemic
threat within a 100 days.
Then, what people colloquially
call, the 200 Day Mission,
which is then the ability to scale that up
and then produce it and distribute it.
When you take that
complexity and then look at
a continent like Africa
and a plan for vaccine
manufacturing, and you think
where should different
platforms be produced,
how can that couple with
routine immunizations,
so that vaccines will actually
be purchased and procured,
it's complex.
I think it's so complex that some people
are just sort of frozen.
What we need to do,
is actually start putting
roadmaps out there,
putting ideas on the table
for how this architecture
can be maintained.
Do you agree with that?
- I do agree with that,
but also to say that
right now, the corporate
sector's leading the effort.
- Okay.
- On the African continent,
Aspen PharmaCare is the biggest company.
So, it has corporate interest and
there is a need to derisk when it comes to
sort of local manufacturing sites.
So, we have to make sure
that we have a proper private partnership
with proper agreements around,
beneficiary built into it.
- So, I think, another thing if I may add,
and first disclaimer, I
sit on the Gavi Board,
but this is my personal
opinion, which is that
one of Gavi's, which was formerly called,
Gavi, The Vaccine..
Now called Gavi, The Vaccine Alliance.
It was called Global Alliance for Vaccines
and immunizations.
One of the mandates, one of the reasons
why countries put money into that entity,
is its market-shaping role.
If there ever were any case
for Gavi flexing its muscle,
is to shape the market
in Sub-Saharan, actually Africa,
not just Sub-Saharan Africa,
continent-wide market-shaping
in favor of sustaining manufacturing.
Having said that,
in order for the capacity to survive,
it will have to be a
market-based solution.
Some players in that ecosystem,
that's the very nature of markets.
We have tried government-led
manufacturing around the world.
It rarely works.
There are exceptions, but it rarely works
truly, wholly nationalized
vaccine manufacturing system.
(device pinging)
So, on the one hand,
I think Gavi has a role to play in this.
On the other hand, it is
through sort of nudging markets,
shaping markets,
not encouraging 100%
nationalized manufacturing.
So, I'll come to...
Sorry,
you were gonna say something.
- No, just to say,
which means we must get procurement right.
- [Saad] Yeah, absolutely.
That's market shaping,
essentially.
- Yeah.
- So, a couple of questions and I'll have
two versions of the same
question from both of you,
from Jennifer and Beth.
Jennifer, I'll start with you.
What are two mistakes U.S.
policy-makers made in this
(object thudding)
pandemic?
- Just two?
(all chuckle)
- Just, well, top two.
- Let me see how I can lump it. (chuckles)
A big enough bin to catch a lot of stuff.
I think Beth hit on it in
terms of that acting fast
and then acting,
(object crashing)
given the possibility
of the worst case scenario.
We saw quite...
This actually happened in COVID
and it happened in monkeypox, same thing.
One was, testing was our critical failure.
The first one was marred by,
the rollout of testing in COVID
was marred by technical difficulties.
But there was a period of time there
where we didn't act on the urgency.
We didn't think, "Hmm,
this could get really bad.
"How can we scale to how badly it can be?"
Then we saw that play out in
COVID, sorry, in monkeypox
where we had the tests already rolled out.
We didn't have to overcome
that technical hurdle
that was already there,
but that infrastructure
was really scaled to a much smaller event.
It wasn't looking ahead
to a more distributed,
community-wide event whereby
you would need to have
testing more distributed.
So, I think that was the
first one, was what Beth said,
sort of failure to think
ahead, how bad could this be
and what do we need to start
putting into place now,
given the possibility
of where this could go?
I think the other thing
was that we really need to
take a hard look at our
health system and make sure
our responses are integrated
into our health system
because that really is the
first point of contact.
But also, I think we need to take a look
at how equipped our health
systems are for these events
and really perhaps
rethink healthcare models.
This just-in-time, very lean
organizations just don't work
when there's an emergency.
And unfortunately there's
lots of emergencies.
It's not just COVID.
I was telling a group of students earlier,
we did a study just before the pandemic,
looking at hospitals in New York City
and how ready they were
for the 2017-flu season,
which rivaled the 2009-pandemic
in terms of volume.
They really, really struggled then.
That was, I think, an omen
for how difficult things
would be in COVID.
- Yeah, you're absolutely right.
So, brilliant capacity of both of you,
actually, all three of you alluded to.
After, in emergencies like
recruiting firefighters
after your house starts burning.
So, you don't call them at that time.
So, I'll ask you, Beth,
what do you think were
the two biggest mistakes
that global policy-makers made?
- Yeah, well, I'll just
say in 2020, I think...
I'll just say that the U.S. Government
was exiting the World Health
Organization, the global stage,
around the time that the
world, in my opinion,
needed U.S. leadership the most.
So, I think that was a huge mistake
and I think that dogged the response
for months and months and
months, and probably still
makes it harder for us when
we are looking at how best
to fix some of these
architectural questions
that I just put up on the screen.
So, that's number one.
I think you can be frustrated
with the global system.
You can be rightly asking for
the global system to do more.
You can look at the
United Nations and say,
"I want you to do better,"
but leaving, exiting,
only hurts people, including
people in your own country.
So, I think that was a
huge, a huge mistake.
The second thing I'll say,
and maybe I'll just bring the
question up to the level of,
what do we, as policy-makers
in the United States
and globally, fail to do
in every emerging
infectious disease crisis
that I've been a part of?
And I'll include myself in this.
I think that we fail to look
at the worst case scenario
and plan backwards from that.
That doesn't mean that we
act without any evidence,
or we put in place things
that are factually incorrect,
but it does mean that we need tools.
Back to some of the things
that Jennifer said in her talk.
We do need tools that are ready
in the absence of information,
in the absence of perfect evidence,
and in the face of the uncertainty
that we will always face
at the beginning of a
public health crisis.
So, we need to be prepared
for the absolute worst
thing that can happen,
or the multiple worst case scenarios.
Not just the thing that we
think most likely will happen.
I'll just say, I think public health,
in general, public health
officials have so little resources
they're trained to be able
to and want to respond
the thing that's most likely
because that's all they can do.
We have to resource public
health appropriately
and train the next generation
of public health leaders
to be thinking about decisions
for the worst case scenarios.
That time that we lose in
not preparing, sets us back
and puts us behind the curb every time.
- I agree.
I couldn't agree more.
I think it wasn't
technology that failed us.
PCR was a technology that
has been with us for decades.
Testing and masks, masks I'm wearing,
this technology is pretty straightforward.
It was designed, actually
even the best version of it,
was designed in 2009, 2010, cetera.
It was governance.
If we don't have the capacity
to make effective decisions,
I think we will continue to
see these kinds of things.
So, I'll open up...
Sorry, you--
- Yes,
I just wanted to add, one
of the things that I think
one of the failures is,
we stumbled on risk communication
- Hmm.
- It's that's partly because--
(Jennifer speaking faintly)
- Something like that.
- Yeah.
- Part of it's the difficulty
of a moving target.
But there were some basic principles
around risk communication
that were simply not followed
by many countries in the world instance.
Inconsistent communication
changed the people speaking
and we stumbled in many respects.
So, the public also had to
face this disinformation
and misinformation.
We understand that, but
in the middle of that,
I think strategies for
better risk communication
they really need to be developed
for the future.
- Well,
you're speaking to the
choir 'cause some of us
were jumping up and down
in February and March.
We did our, here at Yale, we
did our first national survey
on February 9th, 2000,
looking at the behavioral
and communications response,
looked at what were the sources
of information that
were trusted, et cetera,
and what should be the response
before it was named COVID.
We did our first national survey
around vaccines on May 9th,
2020.
So, you're absolutely right.
And we thought, as a global community,
that we need to bring the best science,
and this is mainstream thinking, forward,
and we need to insist on the rigor
of vaccine development science,
but not the rigor on vaccine
communication science.
And that was...
Very sensible folks thought
that it was just furrowing your brow
and speaking on prime
time TV was sufficient.
And there were no principles,
no evidence to be utilized
in terms of how to
effectively communicate.
So, you are absolutely right.
And next time we better not do that.
But monkeypox is not a good sign for that.
So, I'm not that optimistic
that this will not happen again.
I think it's not...
It's up to the next generation
of public health leaders
and scholars and
(zipper screeching)
implementers
and policy developers to make sure
that this is not an afterthought.
- I think we also need people
who are training in public health
and people who are
training in basic science
(object crashing drowns out)
to do cross-strains--
- Yeah.
- even more effectively.
And what I mean by that,
is that we were developing
new vaccine platforms
that had never been used
for mRNA vaccine platforms,
while you were trying to
communicate to the public
about how they should trust
these vaccines.
- Yeah.
So, the scientific development was amazing
and revolutionary, but that
set us back even further
with the trust and science communication
because we were not
just talking about tools
people were already nervous
about, some segments of society.
We were talking about brand new tools
that hadn't actually been tested before.
So, I think figuring out how to have
that kind of communication with the public
around a new and uncertain science,
makes it even more complicated.
- That's absolutely true.
So, we'll jump to questions
from participants and audience,
but we'll go to online
questions first, so, maybe...
Yes?
- [Assistant] I have two questions,
I think this might be for Wilmot,
related to vaccine manufacturing
in those seven countries
that were kind of identifiers.
Why were they chosen?
So, that's maybe question one.
The second question, for those countries,
are there plans for skill-building
to ensure sufficient
human resources as well?
- Excellent question.
The choice of countries,
when it came to developing the spokes
for the mRNA transfer technology,
was a selection made by the WHO.
That had to do with whether
there was existing partners
in those countries on various aspects.
So, Tunisia for example,
is very well-positioned
on the bioinformatic side,
but it lacks others and so on.
So, that was one set of criteria.
The other had to do with
what companies chose.
So, companies chose to cite work in Kenya,
which makes a lot of sense.
Kenya has a lot of interest and experience
in developing animal vaccines
because of the animal health experience.
South Africa probably
has the longest reach.
So, part of it's just company choices,
so it's a combination of those things.
- [Saad] Any other question from?
- [Assistant] Sure.
Second question--
- Can you say the name
of who's asking?
- Sure.
Jennifer, this question comes from
Dr. Christina Towers (speaking faintly)
who you met earlier today.
She was appreciative of your
note, when you noted that
one thing you would invest in
was community health workers.
Could you expound on
that a little bit more?
Why and how you feel
that would help prepare
for the next. (faintly speaking)
- Yeah, I think community health
workers have the potential
to touch on many areas that
we saw deficiencies in.
One is clearly on health
services and reaching people
and continuing to provide,
not just care for pandemic-specific care,
but also all the other
care that has to happen
during the pandemic that doesn't stop.
I think we cannot put blinders
on and only focus on a virus
and not consider the whole
health needs of communities.
And that's, I think,
a lesson that we learn
every time there's an emergency.
So, community health workers are important
for supplementing the
care and extending care
and providing care where
community needs are.
But they also potentially help
on the risk communication side.
I think that was clearly something
that we had a hard time doing.
We didn't really have plans for
as Beth and Wilmot and Saad
said, talking about, we were
great on the technology,
(object clatters)
but we didn't think about
how we were gonna roll it out
and get people to wanna take it.
I will just tell you, anecdotally,
in the last two years,
I have talked to hundreds
and hundreds of people
about COVID vaccines.
And one of the key
commonalities that I have found
in those conversations when
people are asking me questions
and they sort of suggest trust,
not sure who to trust may be an issue,
they commonly don't have
a healthcare provider
in their lives.
So, making sure we have people
who are in people's lives,
not just, suddenly they show
up in the midst of a pandemic,
but they're in people's lives day to day,
dealing with the various
medical issues that could arise
throughout someone's lifespan,
then to also be able to broker
conversations about vaccines,
to be able to connect people
to the services they need
and to be able to get connected,
that sort of bottom-up
approach is really important.
- Yeah, absolutely.
Even in your work you
talked about, Wilmot,
that healthcare providers
were the most trusted
source of vaccine information.
We've been finding in a lot of those work
for the last 22 years, consistently shows,
irrespective of geography,
the top most trusted
source of vaccine information
is a healthcare provider.
So that means access to a
healthcare provider, but also...
Again, one of the most lost
opportunity in this country was,
and beyond, frankly as well, was a lack of
a national CME program to
train healthcare providers
on evidence-based communications methods.
- Yeah.
- And it exists.
At Yale, we created a CME.
It's the most subscribed CME program.
The second-most was a third of attendance
where people took it for certification.
And that was states mandatory CME.
So, there is a demand out there,
but you were saying something
else, I guess, as well?
- No, I was gonna say,
there's enormous variation.
So, healthcare workers obviously
come first as a category,
but the most trusted
institution in Tunisia,
is the military.
The most trusted institution in the Congo,
is a Catholic Church.
And the most trusted
institution in South Africa
is the President of South Africa.
It's enormous variation
about how trust works.
Also, just to quickly answer
the second part of that question
that I failed to answer,
is that when it comes to
vaccine manufacturing,
you're talking about the
ecosystem you build around,
including relations with universities,
where most of your scientists are located.
And then as I pointed
out, where the gap is,
is training in good manufacturing practice
in making vaccines.
This is the pharma side, on
the pharmacological side,
that's where the gap is and
to what's required is a fund,
a scholarships fund, to
train people in that area.
That takes a little
while, so in the meantime,
there's a need to import skills.
- Beth, I'll ask the
next question from you.
When you talk to folks
and public health leaders
specifically around the world,
especially in low and
middle-income countries,
not everyone is on board
with the term biosecurity
and biopreparedness, and even where
whatever version of the word security is.
So, you sometimes get pushback from there.
Any other thoughts on framing
our collective preparedness
in those terms?
- Yeah, I think one thing I'll say is,
that it depends on who you talk to.
So, if you're talking to
public health officials,
sometimes there is concern
with using that term.
If you're talking to leaders
in ministries of foreign affairs,
or in national governments
at the highest levels,
there's less concern.
That again, that's a broad generalization,
and it really depends on
the country that you're in
and the people that you're talking to.
So, I always start by defining
what I mean by health security
because it makes it clear
that I'm talking, not only about security
as in national security,
or national defense,
I'm talking about security for people,
our public security and our public safety.
I like the term health security.
I think that it's an important term.
I think that we should continue to use it,
but I think it has to be framed
in the context of the
broader health system.
I think that you just
made an outstanding point
in the conversation
about healthcare workers
and community health.
If we don't actually have
a strong healthcare system,
we know that we're not going
to have global health security.
So, you have to look at
those two things together.
But I do think that there is a touchiness
amongst some in the health community
to using the security terminology.
One challenge I find with that,
wherever you sit on that debate,
is that when we have a
crisis, like COVID-19,
pretty quickly things move
from ministries of health
as spokespeople
(objects clatter)
up to level of government.
And that's always going to happen.
You're going to have
prime ministers and presidents speaking.
You're going to have ministries
of foreign affairs involved.
And so, you have to recognize
that security is part of the equation.
It is.
It absolutely is.
So, the question is
how do we work together
to solve this challenge as a public health
and a national international
security issue because it is.
I think COVID-19 clearly showed that.
So, that is another reason
why I'm really in favor
of cross-training people who
go into political sciences
and end up in pandemic preparedness
and people who go into public health
and end up in pandemic preparedness,
so they don't meet for the first time
in the Situation Room at the White House.
- And maybe, can I just add to that?
Because I heard there
was a debate at one point
and particularly when we looked
at the rollout of vaccines globally,
and the stark disparities that we saw,
there was this kind of
rising debate that this was
as a result of our securitization
of our health threat.
The idea being that countries
wanting to preserve their own security
were therefore hoarding vaccines
and not giving it to others and that
had we not viewed the crisis
through the security lens,
that perhaps that wouldn't exist.
I will tell you, from
working in this field
for more than 20 years,
I fundamentally reject that interpretation
because, let me tell you,
the hoarding has persisted
long before we ever started
using the word health security.
We saw it happen exactly in 2009.
Before that was really a
term that was thrown around,
countries in emergencies,
particularly when they're unprepared
and particularly when we don't have
global mechanisms for sharing,
we'll do just what we saw them do.
Every single tabletop exercise
we've been in with leaders,
they tend to have that tendency.
So, I don't think it's the securitization.
I think it is the false understanding
of what it means to be secure.
And being secure means,
not just looking inward,
but also seeing how
events that happen outside
affect what happens inward.
- So, I'll take the next few
questions towards the end of,
yeah, go.
- I Just wanna make
one little point.
It's just, there are lots of Ebola samples
that are unaccounted for.
So, the question of laboratory biosecurity
and the transportation
of pathogens security,
is of the greatest importance
and we need to upscale that.
That's all I'll say.
So, those who talk about
biosecurity not being
an important component,
(Wilmot faintly speaking)
- Remember all the disaster movies start
with a scientist warning about exactly
this kind of
(all laughing)
lots of Ebola.
- You can make agents from scratch
and there's very little regulation
around the world--
- That is true.
- about this topic.
So, given that, anyone
who goes to public health
needs to be thinking about
diseases that are propagated
intentionally, or accidentally.
That doesn't mean conspiracy theory.
It means this is a fact
that you have to deal with,
and that means public health and security
have to work together.
You will work with the security community,
(device pinging)
if you're not already.
So, getting comfortable
with that is important.
- Yeah, so Maddie, yeah, go.
- [Maddie] Hi, Beth,
this question's for you.
I'm wondering if you have in
mind a country, or an entity,
that has really put
together the architecture
and the pieces that you're talking about.
What is a model that we could work toward?
Are there any?
- That's a great question.
I think (chuckles)
a couple of us should
answer that question.
I don't have one country.
The model that I think
fundamentally will work,
has to rely on countries being prepared,
so filling the priority
gaps that they've identified
through an evaluation
that either they've done,
or an external organization has done.
At the next layer,
we need to have strong
regional institutions.
I think the African
Union is a great example
of a regional institution
that flexed in a crisis
where they weren't able to get access.
They were able to build internal tools
for a continent of over 50 countries.
That kind of regional
strength is important
because not every country
is going to be able to have everything.
At the global level, we
have to have institutions
that can help develop
and invest in vaccines,
deliver tests and treatments
to those that can't get them.
So it, it has to be at all three levels.
I don't think any one country can do it.
I do think that there are some countries,
when you look at just how
well they work internally
across sectors, that
are doing a great job.
One of the reasons
that the Global Health
Security Agenda was launched
with a number of countries,
including Finland in 2014,
is because at the time, and
I believe this is still true,
the Government of Finland had
a very strong interagency mentality
with the ministries of health,
defense, foreign affairs,
and agriculture, worked
really closely together.
I think that is a model that
we need in order to be prepared
for any kind of health threat
within individual governments.
It's also true for the U.S. Government.
I know it's not easy to
see from the outside,
but there is constant communication.
We just have a slightly
bigger system to hurt the cat.
- So, my last...
Sorry, Wilmot--
- I was gonna
just add one thing.
We need much better
leadership on this issue.
The leaders are elected,
so you get what you get.
There's no resume to evaluate,
but you need, below presidents,
you need a very strong cadre
of public health professionals
that provides stability
in terms of leadership on
the civil service part.
- [Saad] Okay, so one
last question from you.
- [Audience Member]
I'm just curious to see
what role can big wealthy
and research grounded universities,
such like Yale and Brown, play
on the global stage for
pandemic preparedness?
- That's a perfect question for you.
- Yeah.
I think a few roles.
What universities do, we conduct research.
We try to gather the evidence
to answer the most pressing questions.
We also educate, we train the
next generation of leaders
(chuckles) to make sure
that we have in place
exactly what Wilmot talks about.
And then, one thing
that I think COVID has,
I think, changed how universities operate
and I hope that this is a
legacy of COVID, which is that
we have to do more translational work.
We have to do more work to
take the evidence and make sure
it gets to the people
who are making decisions
and continue to push on them
to make the right decisions
based on the evidence.
That piece, I think
there will always be room
for independent credible
voices to both evaluate
what governments are saying,
as well as continue to educate,
not just people in our
programs, but the general public
for how they can protect themselves.
So, I think that translational
piece will be, hopefully,
a bigger piece of the portfolio
of what universities do.
- Yeah, no, I think that's
a good place to end.
I resisted rephrasing that question as,
"What can Brown do for you?"
(all laughing)
but thank you all for being here
for your insightful responses.
And thank you for you all for being here
and for your questions,
both from within this room
and online.
So, with that, we end this panel.
Thank you.
(audience applauding)
(whimsical music)